The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Hey, everyone.
Good on that?
All right, cool.
So today we're going to talk
about the economics of spam
and security in general.
And so up to this
point in the class,
we've mainly talked about the
technical aspects of security.
So we've looked at things
like buffer overflows,
the same-origin policy, Tor, and
all kinds of things like that.
And so the context
for that discussion
was that we were looking at
how an adversary can compromise
a system.
We tried to devise
a threat model that
would describe the types of
things we want to prevent,
and then we tried
to think about how
we could design systems
that would help us to defend
against that threat model.
So today we're going to look
at an altered perspective.
And the perspective
that we'll look at today
is, why is the attacker trying
to compromise your system?
Why is the attacker trying to
do these evil things to us?
And so there's a
bunch of the reasons
you can imagine why
attackers might be
trying to do these evil things.
So some of these attacks are
done for ideological reasons.
So think about
people who perceive
themselves to be political
activists, or things like that.
Or if you think about
Stuxnet, for example.
Sometimes it's like governments
attacking other governments.
And so for these
types of attacks
money, economics, is not
the primary motivation
for the attack to take place.
And what's interesting
is that it's actually
hard to make these attacks go
away, other than generically
making computers more secure.
There's not really some
financial thumbscrew
you can turn to make these
attackers disincentivized
to do things.
However, there are
some types of attacks
that do involve a strong
economic component,
and those are some of the things
we're going to look at today.
One of the interesting
things, though,
is that for a lot
of these attacks
that don't have an economic
component, in that we
can't use regulations and things
like that to try and prevent
them.
It can sometimes be
difficult to figure out
how we'd be able to stop them
at all beyond, like I said,
just trying to make
computers more secure.
For example, Stuxnet's
a great idea.
So this is the malware
that was attacking
some of the industrial software
in Iran, with the centrifuges.
So we all kind of know where
Stuxnet came from, right?
We basically know it was the
Americans and the Israelis.
Basically.
But can we prove that
in a court of law?
Like, who can we sue, to say
You put Stuxnet on our machine?
So it becomes a
little bit murky when
you have some of these
attacks, where it's not clear
you can sue the Federal
Reserve, or you can sue Israel,
for something like this.
And furthermore, no
one's gone on the record
as officially claiming
that it was them.
So there's some very interesting
legal and financial issues
that get involved
when you look at how
to prevent these attacks.
So there are many
kinds of computer crime
that are driven by
economic motivations.
So for example, state-sponsored
industrial espionage,
for instance.
So this is one thing that
some of our previous speakers
have talked about.
Sometimes governments
try to hack
into other governments
or other industries
to steal intellectual
property, or things like that.
And what's interesting is that,
like the attacks that we'll
look at today, which
are spam, you'll
see that actually take some
money to make some money.
Spammers actually have to
invest in an infrastructure
before they can actually
send these messages out.
And so if you have these
attacks where it takes money
to make money, and
you can figure out
what that financial sort of
tool chain looks like, then
maybe you can think
about applying
upstream financial pressure to
stop that downstream malware
attacks or security problems.
And so I think the
take-home point
is that if we look at the
context of spam in particular,
spammers will stop sending spam
if it becomes unprofitable.
One of the sad truths of
the world that we continue
to get spam messages
because it's cheap for them
to send them, and 2% to 3%
of our fellow human beings
will actually click on
links and look at stuff.
And so as long as these costs
for sending these messages out
are so low, then even if
the hit rates are low,
people can still make money
off that kind of stuff.
So for today we're
going to look at attacks
that have a significant
economic component to them.
And so one interesting
example which I actually just
read about takes place in China.
And so in China they
have this problem
with what they call
text message cars.
So the basic idea here is
that people drive around
with these cars that have
these radio antennas attached
to the side.
And they can essentially
do-- think of it
almost like a man in the middle
between people's mobile cell
phones and the actual
cellphone tower.
And so they can basically run
around in these troll cars,
and they can get all of
these cell phone numbers,
and then use that car to
send spam messages directly
to the numbers that
they've collected using
this sort of vehicle take.
So these text message
cars can actually
send upward of 200,000
messages a day,
which is an incredibly
high number.
And the cost of labor over
there is actually very cheap.
So it's very inexpensive
to hire a driver,
drive around one of
these cars, and just
snoop on people's traffic
and send them spam.
So let's look at the
economics of this.
So what is the cost
of the evil antenna,
this thing that
allows people to take
these messages off the air?
Roughly speaking, it's
somewhere in the order of about
1600 bucks, give or take.
So how much profit can
these people make a day?
So in a hilarious
coincidence, this
is also roughly 1600 dollars.
So this is very interesting.
What this means is that once
you buy one of these things,
then in a day essentially
you've made back your money.
So that's great, from the
perspective of being a spammer.
Now you might say, OK, but you
might get caught by the police
and then you might get put in
jail or have to pay a fine.
So in the case of the fines,
the fines for getting caught
are less than 5K.
And people rarely get caught.
And so these are the
types of calculations
we have to look at
when we're trying
to think about how
to economically deter
these spammers.
Because if these
spammers only get
caught a couple times a
year, and they basically
make back their hardware
costs in a single day,
it's very tricky
to figure out how
we can use financial
disincentives to make them
stop doing this kind of stuff.
And what's interesting is that
in China the mobile carriers
are also somewhat
implicit in this scheme.
So every time you
send a spam, you're
going to send some small amount
of money to the mobile carrier,
right?
A couple cents.
It works that way
over here as well.
Now over here in
Europe in many cases,
the mobile carriers
have decided that they
don't want angry customers
contacting them saying,
I'm getting hit by these
spam messages all the time.
But apparently a lot of the
Chinese mobile carriers,
at least the top
three ones, they're
actually seeing
these spam messages
as a source of revenue.
They actually think this
is a nice way for them
to get some free money.
So in fact these telcos
have set up these things
called 106 prefix numbers.
I don't know if you've
heard of these before.
[BANGING]
But the original-- there's
apparently a ghost in the room.
The original purpose
of these numbers
was to do things for
non-commercial reasons.
For example, imagine
that you run a company,
and you want to send a
bunch of text messages
to all of your employees.
You can use one of
these 106 numbers,
and you would basically be
able to send things in bulk.
You'd be able to avoid some
of the built-in rate-limiting
mechanisms they had
in the cell network.
So there's this nice
thing sitting around
that spammers can actually use.
And so as it turns
out, I think it's
something like 55% of the mobile
span that gets sent in China
comes from one of
these 106 numbers.
So this is a really
interesting case study
of how these financial
numbers work out,
and how sometimes
you can actually
have these sort of perverse
incentives, where in this case
the cellphone carriers
are just going along
with these scams
and these schemes.
And there'll be a link
in the lecture notes.
There's an interesting
Economist article about this.
[BANGING CONTINUES]
There is like a pan-African
drum circle back there.
This is super exciting, though.
I like it.
I am being
adversarially attacked.
That's OK.
We will play through the pain.
Perhaps this is the Mossad.
They don't want me to
talk about Stuxnet.
Another interesting
thing about security
is that there are actually
many companies that
deal in cyber arms.
So this is kind of
something out of G.I. Joe,
but there are actually these
companies that will sit around
and they will actually
sell you malware,
they will sell
you exploits, they
will sell you things like this.
So one example is this
company that's called Endgame.
And so for example for
about $1.5 million,
Endgame will give
you IP addresses
and the physical locations of
millions of unpatched machines.
So they have sort of vantage
points all over the internet,
and they know all kinds
of interesting information
about machines that
you may or may not
want to attack if, for
example, you're a government,
or if you're another agency
or something like that.
For about $2.5 million,
they will give you
what is delightfully called a
zero-day subscription package.
And so if you sign up for
this, then basically you
will get 25 exploits
a year, they
claim, for that much money.
And so you'll get those exploits
in your inbox or whatever.
Once again, you can do with
these things whatever you want.
You've clearly got
2.5 million dollars,
so you've got a lot of spare
time to think about this stuff,
presumably.
And so what's
interesting is that a lot
of people who work in
these cyber arms dealers,
they're actually ex
three-letter agencies.
They're ex-CIA, or ex-NSA,
or things like this.
It's interesting
to think about who
are the actual customers of
these cyber arms dealers.
Some of them are
actually governments,
like the American
government, for example.
And they use these things
to attack other nations,
or whatever.
But some of the people
who buy this stuff
are actually,
increasingly, companies.
So one thing we'll
talk about a little bit
at the end of the lecture is
how sometimes companies are now
taking cybersecurity
into their own hands
and sometimes doing
what's called hackbacks.
So without getting the
government involved,
companies that are
attacked by cybercriminals
will sometimes go
back and explicitly
try to take out people
who tried to steal
their intellectual property.
And they've used some very
inventive legal arguments
to justify this, and
so far it's actually
been fairly successful.
So this is an interesting
aspect of cyber warfare.
AUDIENCE: How is
any of that legal?
PROFESSOR: Well, so.
I mean, information
wants to be free, dude.
Right?
So if you think about stuff
like this, for example.
Just telling you stuff
isn't necessarily illegal.
I mean, it gets a
little bit gray.
But for example, if I tell
you that look over there,
there's a house, and the lock
doesn't work on that door.
Can I have 20 bucks?
That's not necessarily illegal.
Because as it turns
out, these companies
have, like, hordes
of lawyers that
look into things like this.
But in many cases, if
you think about it,
you can search for
stuff on the internet
and go to websites that tell you
things like how to build bombs,
for example.
Just posting that
information typically
is not illegal, because
you're just learning.
What if I'm a
chemist, for example?
Or something like this.
So a lot of times, just
giving someone knowledge
is not necessarily illegal.
But you're right that
there's some gray areas here,
and as we'll talk about with
some of these hackbacks,
it's not always clear.
For example, if I am a bank, I'm
not a government, I'm a bank.
I get hacked.
It's not always
clear that I actually
have the legal
authority to go back
and, let's say, try to shut down
a botnet or things like that.
Companies have done
stuff like that.
But I think this is an
example where the law is
lagging behind practice.
And so people have
used things like,
we will use copyright
infringement law
to attack botnets as a company.
Because they're selling
legal goods of ours,
so we'll use IP infringement.
Like, this is probably
not what Thomas Jefferson
was thinking when
he was thinking
about how these laws work.
So this is a little bit
of a cat-and-mouse game.
So we'll do a little bit of
that later in the lecture.
So, yes, this is
very interesting.
Basically what this all
means is that there's
this marketplace for all kinds
of computational resources
that you might use as someone
who wants to launch attacks.
So for example,
there's a marketplace
for compromised systems.
So, for example, you
can go to the darker
places of the internet,
you can purchase
entire compromised machines
that might be part of a botnet.
You can actually buy access
to a compromised website,
for example.
You might use that website
to post spam, or put up
evil links, or things like that.
You can also get access to
compromised email accounts,
like Gmail or Yahoo accounts.
As we'll talk
later, those things
are very very powerful
for an attacker.
And you may also just buy
sort of a subscription
service for a botnet.
You'll just have this
thing lying around.
You can use it to send denial
of service attacks or things
like that.
So there's a
marketplace for that.
There's a marketplace for tools.
So you can get, as an attacker,
off-the-shelf malware kits,
for example.
You can use perhaps
arms dealers like this
to get access to
zero-day exploits
so you can write your own
malware, so on and so forth.
And there's also
a big marketplace
for stolen user information.
So this is stuff like
Social Security numbers,
credit card numbers, email
addresses, so on and so forth.
So it's all out
there on the internet
if you're just willing
to look for it.
And so the paper
that we're going
to look at today
basically focused
on one aspect of this,
which is the spam ecosystem.
And so in particular,
they look at the sale
of pharmaceuticals, of
knockoff goods, and software.
And so they basically
break this spam ecosystem
into three parts.
They break it into advertising.
So this is the
process of somehow
getting a user to click
on a spam link somehow.
And then once they've
done that, there's
this issue of click support.
So this is the notion that
once the user clicks the link,
there has to be some type of
web server, DNS infrastructure,
so on and so forth
on the back end that
actually presents the spam
website that the user goes to.
And then the final
part is realization.
So this is actually
allowing the user
to say they want
to buy something.
The user sends money
to the spammers,
and the user's going to get some
product back in the back end.
And so this is where all
of the money makes place.
And so a lot of this
stuff is actually
outsourced to what the paper
calls affiliate programs.
And so you can think of
these affiliate programs
as essentially doing a
lot of the back-end grunt
work of talking to banks
and Visa and MasterCard
and things like this.
And so a lot of
times, the spammers,
they don't want to
deal with that stuff.
They just want to
create the links
and do-- you can think of it
as the advertising component.
And so a lot of
times the spammers
themselves, they will
work on a commission.
So they will get, let's
say, anywhere between 30%
and maybe 50% of the final
sale that they deliver to one
of these back-end affiliates.
So does that all make
sense at a high level?
OK.
So what we'll do is we'll look
at each component of this spam
trajectory, and then see how
it works, and then maybe think
about how we'd to be able
to shut down spammers
at different levels
of this [INAUDIBLE].
So the first thing we'll look
at is the advertising component.
And so, like I mentioned, the
basic idea of the advertising
is, how do you get the
user to click on a link?
That's the primary question
we'll be concerned with here.
And so the typical
thing, as we all know,
is you're going to email
spam, although as we discussed
at the beginning
of lecture, people
are starting to use
text messages and some
of these other forms
of communication.
You could also imagine
maybe here we're
going to start using
social networks as well.
So now when you go
to Facebook, not
only are you polluted by
your real friends' content,
you're also polluted
by spam messages too.
So this is about
economics, this discussion.
So one interesting
question is, how much
does it cost to actually
send out these spam messages.
And so as it turns out, it's
not very expensive at all.
For about 60 bucks, you can
spend a million spam messages.
So that's a super,
super low cost.
And this cost is
actually much lower
if you're directly
operating a botnet.
You can cut out the middleman.
But even if you are
renting one of the botnets
from one of these marketplaces,
this is still super, super low.
AUDIENCE: So how many of
those are actually effective?
As in, they don't get filtered?
PROFESSOR: Ah, so
that's a good question.
So that leads to my next point.
So you're sending
a million spams,
but then they're
going to get dropped
at various points along the way.
They're going to get
caught in spam filters,
people will-- they see it
but they just delete it
because they know that
an email that has, like,
18 dollar signs should
just be deleted.
So if you look at
the conversion rate,
you'll see that the
click rates are actually
very low because of
things like spam filters
and stuff like that.
And also many users are
trained to avoid these things.
Click rates are low.
And this is why
sending spam has to be
super, super cheap,
because you will not
get a lot of conversions.
So for example, there have been
some empirical studies that
looked at these click rates.
And one study found that they
looked at 350 million spam
messages, and they
found that out
of those 350 million
messages, there
was only about 10,000
clicks on those messages.
So there's a massive
dropoff here.
And then out of
these 10,000 clicks
there were only 28
purchase attempts.
So that's super, super low.
And so that's why it's
extremely important
for this entire ecosystem to be
very cheap from the perspective
of a spammer.
Because I mean, look
at these dropoffs here.
These are multiple
orders of magnitude.
And so that's why one might
hope that at least in theory we
could squeeze--
like for example,
we could drive this
number up maybe just $10.
Maybe that has some
catastrophic knockdown effect
on how profitable this stuff is.
So it's very important
for the spammers
that everything be
as cheap as possible.
AUDIENCE: So those
10,000 clicks.
Again, how many of
those 350 million emails
were filtered out of the inbox?
I'm just trying to get a sense
of out of how many emails
those clicks were
out of, to gauge
how effective spam filtering is
versus how silly us humans are.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, that
I'm not actually sure.
That's a good question.
AUDIENCE: So I was just
listening to a talk
by Jeff Walker on
Friday about this stuff,
and he says that on
the order of 20% to 40%
of clicks going to one of
these websites actually
goes from a user's spam folder.
So users go in their spam
folder, looking for this stuff,
and they click on it.
So presumably there's
a class of customers
that are looking for
this, and if they're
looking for it-- oh, yeah, I'll
just go into my spam folder
to find this.
So it's not clear that things
going into spam folders
are getting zero clicks.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, I've heard
anecdotal reports of that too.
Some people, even for
legitimate emails,
they'll mark it as spam
just so that if there's
a shoulder-surfer,
like at work, who's
seeing them go to
Gmail, let's say,
they won't come and see that
you've subscribed to, you know,
whatever.
And then they can secretly
go into the spam folder,
they know it's not deleted,
and look at this stuff.
This is actually a
really interesting point.
There's this whole
psychology of who
it is that actually
clicks on these links.
And so I think one of the papers
that I linked to in the lecture
notes talks about why these
Nigerian scams still work.
Because you'd think that
anyone who basically
has either common
sense themselves,
or a friend who
has common sense,
would never click on one of
these Nigerian email scams.
Right?
But it turns out that the
Nigerian meme is actually
useful for spammers
to filter out idiots.
In other words, if you are so
foolish that you would still
click on a Nigerian
email, then oh, OK, you're
going to do one of these
conversion things here.
When you think about it,
that's one of the key things
that spammers need.
They need people
who are gullible
enough or idealistic enough to
click through on these things.
There's a whole sort of
psychology behind this.
It's very interesting.
AUDIENCE: So each of these
purchases, about how much
are they worth?
PROFESSOR: That's
a good question.
So it actually depends
on the type of thing
that you're looking at.
A lot of these purchases are not
actually super high in value.
So you're thinking that
someone's buying herbal Viagra
or they're buying like
a knockoff Windows
license or things like that.
And in fact, a lot of times when
they're buying these knockoff
products, presumably
the price is
lower than what they'd actually
get in the real market,
because otherwise you could
just go down to your local mall
and buy these things.
So a lot of times these
purchases you're actually
making are less
than 1,000 dollars,
and oftentimes a
lot less than that.
Any other questions?
OK.
So these conversion rates
are super, super low.
So like I said, one
of the key things
to do as a defender is to
try to basically make spam
more expensive for the spammer.
So there's a couple
different ways
you might think
about doing that.
One way you might think about
doing that are IP blacklists.
So maybe ISPs or
someone else basically
collects this list
of IPS that are
known to be bad, that are
known to come from spammers.
And then we just don't let
these people send traffic.
So this kinda-sorta used
to work for a while.
But now it's so much
easier for the attackers
to use techniques like
DNS redirection and stuff
like that, that we'll talk
about in a little bit,
this doesn't actually
work out very well.
Because now there's a much
larger set of addresses
that spammers can
send spam from,
and they can also
dynamically switch
the binding between
hostnames and web servers
and all these types of things So
this doesn't work out so well.
Another idea that's been
around for a long time
is charging for email in some
way, so each email you send,
you have to pay
some micropayment.
So that currency could be
a couple different things.
So you might imagine
that if I wanted
to send you an email,
maybe I'd have to pay
a tenth of a tenth of a penny.
And that's no big deal
for me, because I don't
send that many emails a day.
But if you're a spammer trying
to operate at these volumes,
then that quickly adds up.
That destroys their value chain.
Another idea that
people have had
is, what if you used
computation as a currency?
This is the idea
that before my email
server will accept
an email from me,
I have to solve some puzzle.
I have to do some math trick,
or something like that.
Once again, that
cuts down the rate
at which these bulk
mailers can send messages.
Also, we're all familiar
with CAPTCHAs, too.
This is basically
the idea that I
have to look at some
picture of nine animals
and find the cat
instead of the dog,
or type in some weird
squiggly number that
looks like a migraine,
or something like that.
So there have been
all kinds of ideas
for charging for email to
stop this kind of stuff
from happening.
One of the classic problems,
though, with all these schemes,
is who's going to be the
first one to implement it.
And if all the email
providers don't move forward
at the same time, then
of course spammers
are just going to migrate
to the email providers that
don't require these techniques.
So there's been the problem
of how do we get everyone
to upgrade en masse.
And there's this
issue of, well, what
would happen if a user
device is compromised?
So maybe if someone breaks
into my Gmail account,
then maybe they're
going to force
me to pay 350 million
micropayments, which
could individually bankrupt me.
And so it's not quite clear
that some of these schemes
are ready for
primetime, but they
do represent an interesting
thought experiment
about how you might be able
to stop some of this stuff
from the senders' side.
AUDIENCE: So how do they work
with mailing lists, where you
have these big mailing lists?
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
so there's problems
with that, and with
mailing list aggregation.
So it's very, very tricky,
because there are actually
some bulk mails that
you do want to send.
I mean, you might imagine
having some heuristic where
you look at the size
of the mailing list
and maybe you scale the
payment according to that.
So for example,
maybe heuristically
you think it's reasonable
to send email to 1000 folks
but not to 350 million folks,
or something like this.
But you're right that there are
a lot of practical limitation
issues that come out
with this kind of stuff.
So what the adversary can do
to get around some of this?
There are basically
three workarounds
that adversaries might try.
So one thing they can
do is just use botnets,
because botnets have a lot of
IPs that the attacker can use.
And so for example,
even if someone
were trying to do something
like IP blacklists,
then maybe the attacker can
cycle through a bunch of IPs
in this botnet and
maybe get around
some of that
blacklist filtering.
They can also try to use
compromised webmail accounts
to send spam.
So the reason why
these are super useful
is because sites
like Gmail or Yahoo
or Hotmail, those services can't
be blacklisted, because they're
super, super powerful.
So if you blacklisted
the entire service,
then you're probably
going to shut down service
for tens of millions of people.
Now of course, these individual
services can shut down you.
And so that will
actually happen once they
have these heuristics running
that see that you're sending
to a lot of people
you've never sent
before, and so on and so forth.
A lot of AI strategy takes
place on the webmail server side
to try to predict these things.
But these things can be
very valuable to an attacker
because even if your
compromised account is not
used to send a lot of emails,
it can be used to send emails
to people that you know.
So maybe it allows the
attacker to do things
like spearfishing more
easily, or things like that.
People are more likely
to click on an email that
comes from an address
that they recognize.
So that's a very
powerful technique there.
And then attackers
can also try to do
things like hijack IP addresses
from legitimate owners.
So as was mentioned
briefly in Mark's talk,
there's this protocol
called BGP that
basically is used to control
routing on the internet.
So there are these
attacks that people
can do whereby they
will essentially say,
hey, I'm actually the owner of
some prefix of IP addresses,
even though they
don't actually own it.
So all the traffic that's
involving those addresses
will go in towards the
attacker, and then they
can actually use those addresses
to send out spam from there.
Then once they're
done with their evil,
they can release the
BGP advertisement
and then go try to do
this somewhere else.
There's a lot of research
in how you can essentially
think of ways to authenticate
BGP by advertisement
or otherwise prevent
these IP address hijacks.
So there's a bunch of
different techniques
that attackers can do to
try to get around some
of these defensive techniques.
So this can all be done,
but still, these defenses,
they're not free.
So presumably the attacker has
to pay for the botnet somehow,
they have to get inside
these webmail accounts.
And so any of these
defenses that you can do
will help to drive the cost
up of generating these spams.
So as such, they're
still useful,
even though they are
not perfect defenses.
So what do these
botnets look like?
So at a high level, you
have the proverbial cloud
from your cloud diagram.
You have your command and
control infrastructure up here,
and this is the
thing that actually
sends commands to all of the
individual bots down here.
So the spammer will talk to
the C&C and will say hey,
here's my new spam
messages I want to send,
and then maybe these bots will
act on behalf of their command
and control infrastructure
and start sending emails
to a bunch of people.
So let's see here.
So why are these bots useful?
Well, as I mentioned here,
they have IP addresses,
which are super useful.
But of course they also have
the associated bandwidth there.
They also have
computational cycles.
Sometimes these
bots are actually
used as web servers themselves.
So these things are
very, very useful.
And they also serve as
a layer of indirection.
So, as we're to discuss in
more detail in a second,
indirection is very
useful for attackers.
That means that if law
enforcement or whatnot shuts
down this level, well, if
the command and control
infrastructure's still
alive, then maybe the spammer
can just attach this
command and control
infrastructure to a
different set of bots
and keep on running.
So that's one reason why
these bots are very useful.
And these bots can scale
to the order of magnitude
of millions of IP addresses.
So as it turns out, people
will click random links
involving malware all the time.
So these things can get
very, very, very large.
And so some of these
takedowns that these companies
get involved in, with trying
to take down these botnets,
they involve millions
upon millions of machines.
So they're very
technically challenging.
So how much does it cost to
get your malware installed
on all these bots?
Remember, these
are all typically
regular end-user machines.
So the cost for getting
your malware on one of these
machines, so price per post,
is about $0.10 for U.S.
hosts and on the order of
$0.01 for posts in Asia.
So it's interesting there's
this differential here.
There might a couple
of different reasons
we can imagine for why that is.
It might be that people are
prone to think that connections
originating from the U.S. are
more likely to be trustworthy.
It may also be that
because there's
pirated software
running here, stuff
that's not actively up to
date with respect to patches.
It's actually easier to
get botnet posts over here.
So you'll see some very
interesting statistics
about how some of these rates
might fluctuate, for example,
as you see companies
like Microsoft go out
and try to stamp down on
piracy and things like that.
But anyway, this is
a rough estimate.
Suffice it to say, this
is not super expensive.
So what does-- any questions
before we continue?
OK.
So what does this command
and control infrastructure
look like?
So you can imagine that in one
substantiation, the simplest
substantiation, this is
just some centralized setup.
And so this is maybe
one machine or maybe
some small number of machines.
The attacker gets to
log into those machines
and essentially just send these
commands out to the botnets
from there.
So if it's going
to be centralized,
then it's going to be very
useful for the attacker to have
what's known as
bulletproof hosting.
So the idea behind
bulletproof hosting
is that you want to put
this command and control
infrastructure on servers that
reside in ISPs that ignore
requests from banks or
from law enforcement
to take down servers.
So there are actually
bulletproof servers that exist.
They charge a premium, because
there is a little bit of risk
involved there.
But if you can manage to host
one of your command and control
centers there, it's
going to be very nice.
Because then when the
American government or when
Goldman Sachs or whoever
says hey, shut this guy down,
they're running spam,
the provider will say,
how can you make me?
I run in a different
legal jurisdiction.
I don't have to follow your
intellectual property laws.
So on and so forth.
So this is very useful.
Like I said, these
types of hosts
actually charge a risk
premium for running
that kind of service.
And so the other alternative for
running the C&C infrastructure
is, this could be a
peer-to-peer network.
And so the idea here is that
maybe this is sort of-- you
can almost think of it as
a mini-botnet up there too.
So the entire control
infrastructure
is spread across many
different machines,
and maybe at any
given time there's
a different machine that's
responsible for sending
commands to all of these
worker nodes down here.
And so this is nice,
because it doesn't
require you to have access to
one of these bulletproof hosts.
You can construct the
C&C infrastructure
using regular bots.
The P2P aspect of it
makes it a little more
difficult to provide guarantees
about the availability
of the hosts that are up
here, but it does have
some other nice advantages.
At a high level, those
are the two approaches
that people can use.
So what happens if the hosting
service gets taken down?
Well, there's a couple things
that the adversary can do.
So they can use DNS to
essentially redirect requests.
So let's say that
someone attacks,
or someone issues a takedown
for the DNS infrastructure
for something like this.
As long as the back-end
servers are still alive,
what the attacker
can do is basically--
the attacker creates lists
of server IP addresses.
And there may be hundreds or
thousands of these IP addresses
that it collects.
And then it will bind
each one to a host
name for a very
short period of time.
So let's say maybe
for 300 seconds.
And so what's nice about
this is that if someone's
trying to run
heuristics that say,
if I see some particular
server sending
more than 1,000 spam-like
messages in a given period
I'm going to try to issue some
kind of takedown to them, well,
these types of techniques will
maybe help the attacker fly
under the radar of those
types of detection techniques.
Because essentially every
300 seconds they're saying,
OK, I'm going to be
serving spam from here,
then I'm going to be serving
spam from here, serving spam
from here, so on and so forth.
So this is a nice use
of indirection, at least
from the attacker's perspective.
And so, as I mentioned earlier,
these types of indirection
are of one of the key
ways that attackers
try to evade law enforcement
and these detection heuristics.
So you might think about,
well, what if we just
take down the DNS server?
How hard is it to do that?
Well, as the paper
describes, there
are a couple different
layers on which
you can attack these spammers.
So you can try to take down the
attacker's domain registration.
That's basically
the thing that says,
like, hey, if you're looking
for russianpharma.rx.biz.org,
then here's the DNS
server that you talk to.
You can imagine attacking
it at that level.
You could also
imagine attacking it
at the level of taking down
the spammer's DNS server,
the thing to which you'll
be redirected once you
look at that top-level domain.
And so what's tricky
is that the attacker
can use these sort of
fast flux techniques
at every different level.
So, for example, they
can rotate the servers
they use to act as
their DNS servers.
They can rotate the web servers
they use to send out the spam.
And so on and so forth.
So that's just a
high-level review
of how people can
use multiple machines
to try to avoid detection.
So as I mentioned earlier,
you can use compromised
webmail accounts to send spam.
And the power of that is
that if you can get access
to someone's account,
then you don't actually
have to install malware
on their machine.
You can actually
access their account
from the privacy of your
own machine, wherever
it is that you're located.
And as we were
discussing earlier,
this is useful for
spearfishing attacks,
because you can send this spam
message as the person whose
account it actually belongs to.
And so as a result
the webmail providers
are very motivated to shut
this kind of thing down.
Because if they don't
do that, then they
risk being blacklisted
as a whole.
All the users risk being flagged
as spam, which they don't want.
And also the provider actually
needs to somehow monetize
their service.
They actually need real
users to be doing things
like clicking on ads
in the righthand bar
of their webmail account.
So the higher the proportion of
their users which are spamming,
the less likely advertisers
are to advertise
in their webmail system.
So the webmail
account providers are
very incentivized to shut
down this kind of stuff.
So how do they try to
detect this type of spam?
They use those heuristics.
They might try to use CAPTCHAs.
If they suspect that you've
sent some spam-like messages,
let's say five
times in a row, they
might ask you to type in
one of those fuzzy letters
or whatever.
Suffice it to say, though,
a lot of these techniques
don't work very well.
If you look at the
price per account,
so how much you
as a spammer would
have to pay to get
one of these things,
it's still super, super cheap.
So it's on the order of $0.01 to
$0.05 for an account on Yahoo,
Gmail, Hotmail,
something like that.
So once again, this
is very, very low.
And so this does not act as
an effective disincentive
for spammers to try to
do these types of things.
So this maybe is a
little bit disappointing,
because it seems
like everywhere we
go, we have to solve
these CAPTCHAs if we
want to buy things
or send emails or do
that kind of stuff.
So basically, what
happened to CAPTCHAs?
They were supposed to make
all this bad stuff go away.
And as it turns
out, the attacker
can build services
to solve CAPTCHAs.
So this can be automated,
just like anything else.
As it turns out, the
economics for this
is that if you want
to solve one CAPTCHA,
then it's approximately $0.001
dollar to solve a CAPTCHA.
Which is nothing.
And this can be done with
very, very low latency, too.
So CAPTCHAs essentially
are not presenting
most large-scale spammers
with a high barrier
for sending these spams.
And so how is this being done?
If it's this cheap,
you might think,
maybe it's being done all
by computers, by software.
But it's not, actually.
So a lot of this
is done by humans.
In particular, the attacker
can outsource this in one
of two ways.
So first of all the
attacker can just
find a labor market
where the cost of labor
is very, very cheap.
So you can employ humans
to essentially act
as CAPTCHA solvers for you.
You, the spammer, are
presented with a CAPTCHA
by Gmail or whatever.
You, the spammer,
then send that CAPTCHA
over to some human
sitting somewhere.
They solve for you, they've
earned some small amount
of money, and then
you send their answer
to the legitimate site.
You could also do this
with Mechanical Turk.
Have you guys heard
of Mechanical Turk?
I've asked the question, my
back is turned, [INAUDIBLE].
OK, so Mechanical
Turk is pretty neat,
I mean neat if you're
trying to do evil.
So what's nice about
that is that you
can post these tasks on
Mechanical Turk and say,
hey, I have a picture-solving
game, or something like this.
Or you can just come
out and say straight up,
I've got some CAPTCHAs
I want to solve.
You post a price, and
then basically the market
will match you with people who
are willing to do that task.
And then they'll do it for
you, they'll post the answers.
So this actually automates
a lot of actually finding
the labor pool for the spammer.
The problem with
this is that you
have more overhead
for the spammer,
because Amazon has to take
some cut of that profit that's
generated from that.
But that's very nice there.
Another thing that
attackers can do
is they can actually reuse
CAPTCHAs on legitimate sites.
So there's some CAPTCHA that
the attacker wants to solve.
They then have some
legitimate site
on the side where they present
that exact same CAPTCHA,
and get a real visitor to
figure out what that CAPTCHA is.
Then they come back
over to the first site
and then use that
answer as the answer.
And like all these
crowdsourcing-type things,
if you don't trust
your users, then you
can maybe replicate the work.
So you send the CAPTCHA to
maybe two or three people.
And then you come back in
and use majority voting,
take whatever that majority
vote was as your CAPTCHA answer.
And so these are
some of the reasons
why the CAPTCHA
defenses don't work
as well as you might think.
So the providers, so for example
Gmail or Yahoo or whatever,
can to try to implement
more frequent CAPTCHAs
to try to push the friction
level up for the spammer.
The problem there is
that then regular users
will get irritated.
So a good example
of this is Gmail's
two-factor authentication.
It's actually a super good idea.
Whenever Gmail will
detect that you're
trying to use Gmail
from a machine
that it doesn't
know about, it'll
basically send you a text
message saying hey, enter
this verification
code into Gmail
before you can actually
continue to use the service.
And so what's funny is that
it's a super great idea,
but at least for me,
I get super irritated
when I have to get
that text message.
Like, I know it's good for
me, but I just get angry.
It's frictionful.
And so I'll do it
if I don't migrate
to a lot of different
machines a lot,
but if I had to do it any
more than I did right now,
it's unclear that I'd feel
as happy about it as I do.
So there's this very
interesting sort
of tradeoff between the
security that people
say that they want and the
security measures that they're
willing to put up with.
So as a result,
it's very difficult
for the webmail providers to
increase the amount of CAPTCHAs
and still keep users happy.
OK, so any other questions
before we move on
to click support?
AUDIENCE: So is one of the
reasons for the non-adoption
of encrypted emails,
besides the [INAUDIBLE]
is that spam filters have
a very, very big part?
PROFESSOR: Ah, because then they
can't inspect messages and see
what's going on.
That's a good question.
I think it's
actually hard to say.
I don't know, because it's a
little bit of a chicken and egg
problem.
So because there isn't a huge
volume of encrypted email,
it's unclear whether
spammers are actually trying
to take advantage of that.
But I could see that
maybe being a problem.
I mean, people
have looked at ways
to do computation
over encrypted data.
So maybe you could think
about doing something there.
But it's always tricky.
So for example,
with spam, people
have these spam filters that
were based on Markov models
and things like that.
So what do the spammers do?
They start making these
images that basically
can't be seen by
the text scanners,
but then have the
spamming content in there.
So it's always an arms race.
All right.
So let's move on
to click support.
So what is this about?
So once the advertising
step has succeeded
and the user is given a link, so
these are clicks on that link,
so the user contacts
some DNS server
after clicking on that
link to basically translate
some hostname that was
in that link to some IP.
And then after that
translation takes place,
the user has to contact some
web server that has that IP.
So to make all this
work, the spammer
has to register a domain name.
And then the spammer
has to run a DNS server,
and then they have
to run a web server.
So this is essentially
what the spammer
has to do to make this click
support thing work out.
So one question you
might have is, well,
why wouldn't the
spammer just use
raw IP addresses, for example,
like in these spam URLs?
And so does anyone have
any thoughts about that?
Why wouldn't you just
have 183.4.4 dot whatever,
instead of having something
like russianjewels.biz?
AUDIENCE: Because
it looks sketchy,
it makes it easier to tell.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So one thing, one would
hope, is that a user would
look at this thing that just
has a bunch of numbers in it,
and they'd say, well,
this clearly seems weird.
As it turns out, this will only
weed out some of the users,
but you're exactly right.
There's a subset of people you
would lose just because nobody
wants to click on that.
Another reason is
that once again,
having this sort of DNS
infrastructure up here
gives the attacker another
level of indirection.
So once again, if the legal
authorities or whoever
shut down the DNS
infrastructure but they somehow
don't manage to shut down
that back-end web server,
then the spammer can
conjure up a different sort
of front end for their
service and maybe
try to use that same web
server on the back end.
So that's another
reason, I think,
that people don't
typically put these raw IP
addresses in their spam URLs.
So another example of how this
redirection comes into play--
how this indirection
comes into play, sorry--
is that these spam URLs often
point to redirection sites.
And so these are sites like
bit.ly, or things like that.
And so in addition to
things like bit.ly,
you could also imagine
that a compromised
website can actually
also act as a redirecter.
You just put the appropriate
HTML or JavaScript in there
that when the user
goes to that site,
it's then going to
redirect the user's browser
to some other different site.
So once again, this
useful because it provides
that level of indirection.
And it actually acts
as a force multiplier,
so you have a single
spamming web server back end,
but then you can name it
using different things.
And that will allow
you to maybe confuse
filters who have blacklisted,
let's say, 10% of your URLs,
but not the other 90% of them.
So this is a very,
very common technique.
And then another thing is
that sometimes the spammers
can use botnets as web servers
or maybe as proxies, as DNS
servers, and so and so forth.
We mentioned this a
little bit earlier,
but this is another example of
how the more machines you have
as an attacker, the more
defense that gives you.
Because you can hide your
evil amongst a watershed
of machines.
All right.
So in some cases, one of the
things the paper talks about
is these affiliate providers.
These affiliate providers kind
of act as evil clearinghouses.
They will help to automate some
of the tedium of interacting
with the banks, and
things like this,
on behalf of you, the spammer.
So one thing you
might wonder is, well,
why can't the law
enforcement just take down
the affiliate providers?
They seem kind of
like a choke point.
And the thing is that
these affiliate providers
are kind of like SPECTRE
from the James Bond movies.
They're very
decentralized themselves.
So it's very difficult to
point to an affiliate provider
at this particular machine,
and we'll just shut down
that particular machine.
Oftentimes the
affiliate providers
are distributed themselves.
So that means that it's
actually pretty tricky for,
let's say, the FBI, to just
go to some affiliate program
and say, thou shalt
not do this anymore.
Another interesting
thing, too, is
that the paper mentions
that in many countries
IP laws are different,
for example.
So the FBI may not be able to
enforce intellectual properties
that we have with
other countries.
And also, according
to the paper,
in many of these spam
forums, the spammers
claim they are providing a
useful, legitimate service
to Western countries.
They say that
essentially, prices
are too high for
some of these things,
in these Western countries,
and that the fact that people
are clicking on demand indicates
there's a legitimate need
to buy Windows copies that
may be riddled with malware.
So a lot of times the
spammers themselves
don't feel that they're
doing anything bad.
And as we'll discuss
a little bit later,
the spammers do often
actually give you
the stuff that you've
paid money for,
which for me was one of the
most surprising outcomes
of the paper.
And so we'll discuss why
that is in a little bit.
So one thing that
the paper talks about
is various takedown
strategies that you
can imagine employing to
try to stop a spammer.
So one thing it
talked about, they
said that only a few
number of registrars host
domains for many affiliates.
And so what that means is
that most of these affiliate
programs are-- there's sort
of this one-to-one binding
between affiliates and
the registrars that
are dealing with their domain
name and infrastructure.
It's very rare that you
have a single domain name
registrar who's going
to be associated
with a bunch of different
affiliate programs.
So what that means
is that in many cases
there's not this, like,
master decapitation strike
you could launch,
where you'd take out
this particular registrar
and then all of a sudden
the entire spam
infrastructure falls down.
They found similar results
for things like web servers.
It's very rare that
one ISP will actually
host a ton of web servers for
a ton of affiliate programs.
This distributed
nature, once again,
makes it very difficult
to say, if we just
take out these three things
then the whole ecosystem just
crumbles.
So that's a little
bit disappointing,
because one would
hope that there'd
be one web server in Evildonia,
where if we could just
take down Evildonia, then people
would stop sending us spam.
That's actually not true.
As we'll see later,
though, that may
be true to some extent
at the banking back end.
And so maybe we can actually
put the squeeze on there.
So anyway, I was alluding to
earlier about this realization
phase.
So the realization phase is what
happens after you, the user,
have decided to buy something.
So the realization phase
consists of two parts.
The user pays for whatever
goods they've bought,
or they want to buy, and
then the user hopefully
will receive those goods.
So either in the
mail because they're
buying some type
of knockoff drug,
or they get some
software download
because they want to get some
fake version of Photoshop
or something like that.
And so the money flow
looks something like this.
We start with the
customer here, and they're
going to tell the merchant hey,
I want to go buy something.
They will send some
credit card info here,
and then the merchant is
going to talk to the payment
processor.
And this is
essentially a middleman
that helps the
merchant, the spammer,
deal with some of the
intricacies of interacting
with the credit card system.
The payment processor will
talk to the acquiring bank.
So the acquiring bank,
that's the merchant's bank.
And then the acquiring bank--
running out of space here.
So, violating all
good design standards,
we will come up here.
So the acquiring bank is
then going to talk to-- they
call them in the paper
the association network,
but just think of this as Visa.
This is the credit
card network up here.
And then finally the
association network,
Visa or MasterCard or whatever,
talks to the issuing bank.
So that issuing bank
is the customer's bank.
And essentially
the Visa or whoever
is going to go to the
customer's bank and say hey,
is this a legit purchase?
Is this a legit transaction?
And if this is a
legit transaction,
then the money
will actually flow
through this entire system.
So this is what the end-to-end
financial workflow looks like.
And so this workflow
can actually
process a lot of money.
So one of the papers that we
mentioned in the lecture notes
shows that a single
affiliate can
get more than $10 million
dollars at this workflow here.
And so in practice, you
might think that oh,
why wouldn't the acquiring
bank or the issuing
bank say, something
looks kind of fishy here?
As it turns, in many
cases, they don't.
And so this gets into this
interesting discussion
about why is it that these
workflows are often tolerated
by the financial system.
For example, why do
spammers properly
classify their transactions?
So if you want to send
something through this system,
you have to tag that transaction
with some type of type.
You have to say, this
is pharmaceuticals,
this is software, this is
whatever, this is whatever.
So you might think
that as a spammer,
you wouldn't actually
want to do this.
If you were selling fake
Flintstones vitamins,
maybe you don't want
to say this is actually
a pharmaceutical transaction.
And what's interesting is
that spammers do actually
properly classify these
transactions in many cases.
And the reason is that there are
high fines if you misclassify.
So essentially what happens is
that these association networks
like Visa or Mastercard,
in many cases
they are OK, perhaps,
with transactions
that are slightly shady.
But they don't want to be blamed
for being a money launderer,
or for trying to
deceive the authorities.
So as long as you properly
classify what you do, then
in a certain sense this
gives the association
networks a little
bit of, well, listen,
they told us what was going on.
Maybe the law was a
little bit unclear.
But we, at least,
Visa or MasterCard,
did not try to hide the
intent of this transaction.
So spammers do oftentimes
properly classify
their transactions.
So that's interesting.
It seems like they're
playing within the confines
of the system a little bit.
So another question
I mentioned earlier
is, why send anything to users?
Because presumably you're a
spammer, so you're a criminal,
right?
So why wouldn't it just be cool
if you just took people's money
and then ran?
I mean, that'd be
the ultimate crime.
So as it turns out, they
actually send things to users
because, surprise surprise,
high fines if they don't.
So it's this very
entertaining system
whereby spammers kind of want
to do things that are legal,
when they actually
can't use Bitcoins yet.
They actually have to work
within the constraints
of this pre-existing system.
So as it turns out, there
are these high fines
if you, and by you
I mean the spammer,
have too many chargebacks.
So a chargeback is
essentially when a customer
tells their credit
card company, hey,
I didn't get the thing that
I was supposed to get that I
bought with your credit card.
Or I got it, but
they didn't like it.
So if you're a spammer and you
have too many customers saying
things like this,
then you will actually
get charged very,
very high fines.
And as we saw earlier, the
clickthrough rates for spam
are super, super low.
The conversion rates
So even just one or two
fines might wipe out
your entire profit
for a month, let's
say, for something like this.
So spammers are really
motivated to avoid these fines
in both cases.
AUDIENCE: Would using
Paypal obscure any of that,
like the relationship
with the bank?
PROFESSOR: Well,
typically, yes and no.
So you can think of those--
Paypal is in many respects
very similar to
Visa or MasterCard.
So it has very similar
regulations that oversee it,
because it bears many of
the same types of risks.
I do think that Visa
has slightly stricter
restrictions on
some of this stuff,
as we'll talk about in a second.
But for all intents
and purposes,
Paypal looks very similar.
AUDIENCE: Is there
any sort of idea
of having a group where you
make some sort of account
and then intentionally go
to a bunch of spammers,
buy a bunch of things, and then
ask for a bunch of chargebacks
whether or not they
send it to you?
So that they incur these fines.
Or report them for
misclassifying things,
in order to just make
them pay these fines.
PROFESSOR: That's interesting.
It's like vigilantes.
AUDIENCE: Spam the spammers.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, exactly.
I don't know if I've
heard anything about that.
I do know that the
spammers do try to detect
people who are trolling them.
So for example, one thing that
they talked about in the paper
a little bit is that
spammers-- so how
did the authors of the
paper determine all this?
They actually got a
bunch of spam messages,
they clicked on
a bunch of stuff.
They got a special
Visa card they
used to purchase this stuff,
and then so on and so forth.
So spammers obviously
don't like this.
And so in the paper they
call this test buys.
Spammers want to
prevent these test buys
from researchers who are trying
to figure out what's going on.
So one thing that some spammers
did-- do, I should say--
is they actually require
proof of your identity
before you can buy something.
So they might ask you to send
a picture of your photo ID,
or something like that.
In particular,
some people started
doing this after Visa tightened
up some of their rules
about spam.
Now, the problem with this
is that most people who
would click on span
apparently are still
reluctant to send their photo
ID to just some random person.
So there's a bunch
of-- I've linked
one of these articles
in the lecture
notes-- there's a bunch
of hilarious commentary
from a spammer bulletin board,
where they say oh no, Visa's
cracking down on us.
We try to ask for
people's photo IDs,
but they don't want to send
it to us for some reason.
And it's so weird that people
wouldn't want to do that,
but they will give them
their credit card number.
But anyway, so long
story short, spammers
are highly incentivized to try
to detect that kind of stuff.
AUDIENCE: So for chargebacks,
if you don't necessarily
want your bank to know that you
were buying these completely
shady items, do a lot of
users actually do chargebacks
if they don't get the item?
Or are they too embarrassed?
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
that's a good question.
I don't know what
fraction of people
are in the set of
people who bought
herbal Flintstones
vitamins, were disappointed
by herbal Flintstones
vitamins, and then,
yeah, told their bank-- but
what's interesting, though, is
that the bank has to
know in the first place
that they're going
to this place,
right, because the
thing went through.
So avoiding the chargeback, I
don't think you're going to--
but by doing the
chargeback, let me say,
I don't think you'd reveal any
extra information to the bank
that they wouldn't already know.
Because they had to clear
the transaction first for you
to actually get it
and be disappointed.
AUDIENCE: So then roughly how
many chargebacks is too much?
PROFESSOR: So some of the
figures I've heard here
are greater than 1%.
So in other words,
if you're a spammer
and you have more than 1%
of your transactions causing
these problems,
you get in trouble.
And I wouldn't be surprised
if it was a little bit lower
than that, but 1% is the
number that I've heard.
All right.
So to me, like I
said, this was one
of the most interesting
parts of the paper.
Because I would have thought
that a lot of spamming just
involved straight-up fraud.
That people clicked on
links, they sent money,
they never got anything.
But as it turns out,
because these spammers have
to go through this
network which has
all these mechanisms
to prevent fraud,
they end up having to actually
ship things over to users.
So that's kind of neat.
And so another
reason why spammers
want to do these things,
properly classify transactions
and actually send
things to users,
is that only a few
banks are actually
willing to interact
with spammers.
And so what this means
is that if the spammer is
getting a lot of
chargebacks, or getting
in trouble with the bank
or the credit card company
or whatever, and
some bank decides,
I can't do business
with you anymore,
there's not a really
large set of other banks
that the spammer could go to
to continue their chicanery.
So one study of this stuff
found that there are basically
only 30 acquiring banks that
spammers were seen to use over
some two-year period.
That's actually not very high.
So there is this
other incentive to not
be too goofy with
the financial system,
because you don't really have
too many other places to go
if you break those
relationships.
So it seems like maybe
this is a good choke point
to try to cut down on spam.
So we've already discussed
how things like botnets
give the attack a
lot of IP addresses.
There's a lot of
different types of hosts
who are willing to run web
servers, so on and so forth.
But this number
actually seems small.
So maybe we can actually
attack spamming here.
But as I alluded to earlier,
it's a little bit tricky
to do this because of things
like differing IP laws,
because of things
like the fact that it
can be sort of tricky to
actually say that spammers
are doing something illegal.
So if you are
using spam messages
to sell someone-- let's make
this up, let's say sugar,
sugar's delicious.
It's not illegal to sell
sugar, even at cut-rate prices.
So even though the
way that you may
have drawn the user
to that purchase
was sort of
duplicitous or gross,
it is not in and of itself
illegal to sell someone sugar.
And so as it turns
out, a lot of spam
sort of falls into
this gray area,
where the things that
the spammers are doing
are distasteful, but maybe
not necessarily as illegal
as you'd think.
Now, for stuff like
pirated software,
there it's much more clear-cut.
But suffice it to say,
it's not always the case
that you can just point to one
of these banks and say hey,
your customers are criminals.
Because that's not always true.
Particularly if there's not a
very strong paper trail that
attaches the financial
transaction to some spam
URL that was the origin
of the transaction.
It's often very difficult to
prove those types of links.
OK, so since this
paper was published,
the credit card networks
have taken some actions.
So this paper actually
made a pretty big splash
when it came out.
And so the association networks
like Visa and MasterCard
and all of them were
wondering, what can we
do to cut down on
some of this spam?
So interestingly, after
the paper came out,
some pharmaceutical companies
and software vendors actually
lodged complaints with Visa.
So if you remember
from the paper,
Visa was the association
network the researchers used
to make these test
buys, these dummy buys.
So it's a little
bit unfortunate,
but that then showed
some of these companies
that hey, Visa can be used
as the association network
to fund some of this
spam, or to translate
some of this spam traffic.
So some people
complained about that.
So Visa made some policy
changes in response
to some of the issues
that were brought up
in the paper and some
of the complaints
that they got as
a result. So now,
for example, all
pharmaceutical sales are now
labeled by Visa as high-risk.
So what this means is
that if a bank acts
as an acquirer for these
high-risk transactions,
then Visa will have some more
stringent regulations they will
put on that merchant-side bank.
For example, they
will require that bank
to engage in a risk
management program,
and they may be audited
more frequently,
and so on and so forth.
So Visa made that change.
And Visa also changed
its operating guidelines.
So its operating
guidelines, now they
explicitly enumerate and
forbid illegal sales of drugs
and trademark-enforcing goods.
So the reason why they did
this is that by tightening up
this language, it is
now easier for them
to issue more aggressive fines
against banks and merchants
that they feel are doing
things like selling
illegal pharmaceuticals or
selling knockoff versions
of watches or things like that.
So once again, there's
still a lot of spam
that's in that gray area where
it's not necessarily illegal.
It's just that the
customers were required
to do certain techniques.
And this is very
useful because now Visa
can drop some much
bigger hammers on folks.
And as I mentioned before,
some of the spammers
tried to react to
this by saying,
well, let's just
prevent these test buys.
Because not only do
security researchers do
these test buys, but the
association networks can
do these test buys too.
So they did some things like
the photo ID type stuff,
and that tended not to
work out super well.
And so at least a few years
after these changes were made,
this did have an impact.
I'm not sure what the latest
state-of-the-art is with
respect to trolling these
Visa policy changes,
but it was kind of cool to see
this paper have this impact
in real life.
So one interesting thing
they mentioned in the paper
is they talked about
the ethical aspects
of doing security research.
And in particular, doing this
research about the spam chain.
To actually understand how some
of this banking stuff worked,
these researchers actually
had to make purchases.
They actually had to
give money to people
in exchange for these products.
And so in the paper they
go through this kind
of semi-hilarious defensive
section where they say,
we totally burned
everything that we bought.
We didn't use it.
We talked to the companies
whose pirated software we
were buying before we got it.
But these things are actually
pretty important to go through,
particularly if you're
within a university setting.
Because as you may
know, if you want
to do anything that involves--
particularly human research,
but anything that might have
these ethical sort of aspects
to it, you have to get things
cleared by lawyers, sometimes
by an IRB, and things like that.
So it's actually pretty
important for them
to jump through these hoops,
because at the end of the day
they have to at least be
somewhat confident that they
weren't supporting some
deeply nefarious activity
in some far-flung
corner of the world.
So that was another interesting
part of the paper, too.
And other people have talked in
this class about things like,
what are the ethics of releasing
zero-day exploits if you
know they haven't been
patched by someone?
So it's a really
interesting aspect
of doing security research.
AUDIENCE: Is there any sort of
oversight on security ethics?
Because in the paper, they
said the IRB wasn't interested.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so that
was super interesting.
Yes.
They said the IRB wasn't
interested, I think,
because there was no
obvious human subject.
But I think that at
most universities,
you couldn't just
say, oh, there's
no direct human
subject, let me just
go buy some stuff from somebody
at the end of a spam link.
And what they describe
in the paper, actually
in the acknowledgment
section, they
thank this whole set of people.
Like, Sally at Legal,
so-and-so at the Philosophers
For Ethical Computing
Association,
and stuff like that.
I don't think there's
actually a, how would
you say it, an
America-wide standard
for doing this type of research.
I know that each
university's IRB
has slightly different policies
of what they do and do not
allow, but I don't think
there's a blanket policy.
AUDIENCE: Out of the
350 million spam URLs
they tracked, of the 28 that
actually responded, is there
any chance that an appreciable
number of those 28 spam
responses were coming from
researchers researching
on spam?
PROFESSOR: Well, it's true
that this type of calculus
is actually one
reason why I think
the authors went to such
lengths to defend themselves.
Because if you think
about it, the reason
why those statistics
are so hilarious
is that it means that if you
were to add five or remove
five, that's the difference
between a spammer being
able to give their
kids, like, a real gift
versus a piece of coal.
Because those
numbers are so small.
So with regard to that
particular [INAUDIBLE]
that I gave you, I don't
know how many of those
were researchers.
But I do think in general--
like I said, the spammers,
they want to take your money.
And so if they could
find some equilibrium
whereby security researchers
could do test buys,
but that had no impact
on their overall sales,
they'd be fine with that.
They just want the money.
But the tricky thing
is that, let's say
that-- let's make some
number up-- half of those 35
were test buys, and
that resulted in people
putting pressure on the banks,
and then instead of 35 they'd
be getting two.
That they don't want.
So that's why they're so
motivated to stop that stuff.
AUDIENCE: How much of
this is blind emailing
versus any sort of filtering?
Because I'm sure they
could run some models
and get that 350 million
down to, like, one page.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so it's all
about the cost-benefit analysis
from the perspective
of the spammer.
So I think that you're right,
and there are actually--
there's a marketplace
for more targeted stuff.
In particular, that's where
some of those compromised email
accounts can become very useful.
But I think what you
see is that people
tend to go for the more
focused stuff, like the more
focused spam emails,
for what they
view as higher-reward targets.
So for example,
political groups.
People associated with the
Dalai Lama, for instance.
There, the perceived
value of being
able to get into that
system is so high
that people will spend the
time to do this kind of stuff.
AUDIENCE: It would
be interesting
if there was one
company dedicated
to finding all the
gullible grandmas
and putting their
emails into stuff.
PROFESSOR: Oh, interesting.
I see.
So basically having
some database
where it's like, totally send
spam to this person, because--
AUDIENCE: It works.
PROFESSOR: I wouldn't be
surprised if stuff like that
existed, but I don't
know if they do.
So one last thing that I
wanted to mention is that,
and I alluded to this a
bit earlier in the lecture,
that some companies have taken
to doing these things they
call hackbacks.
So the idea is that, let's
say that you're a bank,
someone tries to
break into your bank
and steal your information.
That bank will then,
of their own volition,
go back to those hackers
and try to do something.
Where something may be as
quote-on-quote innocuous
as shutting down
the botnet, or maybe
they try to steal
their information back,
and things like that.
This has actually
become very much more
common than it used to be.
And one reason for this is that
because the legal system has
a little bit slow in adapting
to some of these threats,
some of these institutions, in
particular software companies
and banks, are tired of
waiting for government--
like, their national
government-- to deal
with stuff.
So what ends up happening
is that, for example, there
was this big botnet
in 2013 that was
hosting all kinds of pirated
goods and things like that.
And so this huge coalition of
Microsoft, American Express,
Paypal, a bunch of them
launched an operation
to take down a botnet.
They themselves took
down the botnet.
They lurked around
for a while, they
learned about where the command
and control infrastructure was.
They actually went
in there, took
control of the command and
control infrastructure,
identified where all
the end-user bots were.
And they could send
them messages saying,
you need to patch your machine.
And so it's a very interesting
area of intersection
between security and the law.
Because what part
of American law,
for example, gave those
companies the right to do that?
So what Microsoft
lawyers said, at least,
is that they said
these botnets were
violating Microsoft trademarks.
So for example, if you
sell pirated goods,
and you're saying this
is Windows, for example,
but it's not actually
Windows or it didn't come
from an official channel,
then Microsoft says OK,
you're violating our trademark.
Therefore we can
hack your botnet.
It's a little interesting to
see how that leap of logic
took place.
But the courts allowed it.
And this is increasingly
happening more and more.
And the banks in particular seem
to be pretty upset about this,
because there seems to be a
lot of state-level sponsorship
of some of these banking hacks.
And the bankers care
about the money,
and so when they
lose this money,
they get very upset about that.
And so it's
interesting to see how
some of the burden
for doing cyber
security, in particular
offensive operations,
has now shifted a little bit
more to the private sector.
So it's not quite clear what
the long-term implications are.
OK.
That's the end of
the lecture, and I
guess we will see
you on Wednesday
and we'll go through
the class projects.